hello welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a
friend I had to take a second there
before we started because Sona was
yelling in the podcast studio and you
two are being dicks
well I don't think that's the right
energy to start a friendly show that
basically has uh is meant for children
oh this is a show by children four
children on an intellectual level yeah
exactly uh Sona what would you and Gorly
were shouting about something and I was
just trying to get you to stop talking
long enough and shouting so that I could
start the the program that's all first
of all it's hard to have a human moment
in this room because every time we talk
about something fun you're like let's
record it because I want to capture the
essence can't some things just be
between us yeah no no it almost be
recorded and then monetize
filthy filthy riches rubies gold uh yeah
well Sona you and Gorly were shouting
about your eyebrows what was that all
about it's about hair removal right I
don't want to talk about this because I
upset Sona and I feel bad oh that's nice
yeah I don't know United you know what I
shouldn't have done gotten upset no I
think you were in the right no that's
not that's not true I shouldn't but I
reacted I always react at a 10 when I
should react at like a two but you had
reason to react I know conflict we at
least let people know what the nature of
the disagreement was well I started off
by saying you know listen
I have certain there's art lit what just
say it I'm I'm a hairy person and I have
eyebrows that if I don't take care of
them they become a unibrow that's just
oh is that is that true your eyebrows
are beautiful thank you that's because
Alma shapes them and takes care of who's
Alma Alma's my girl oh she does it with
your permission it's not like she comes
in the night you wake up
I wouldn't mind it and then Matt says
you also said you have a unibrow and I
was like oh do you just take care of it
yourself and then you said the way you
said it I just snapped it your eyebrows
would grow together if you didn't
intervene yeah I have what would connect
like I wouldn't call it like a London
Bridge but it's like a rope Bridge you
know like it gets it has a little bit of
a sag to it yeah it's like a Raiders of
the Lost Ark exactly yes it's like a um
actually it's template do but let's you
know go ahead oh okay all right how
about the man who would be king kind of
bridge there we go okay yeah with Sean
Connery and Michael Michael Kane all
right Michael Kane yeah that's amazing
that's a great movie right here what
year 64. of course oh no much later than
that I know that's a movie from the 70s
okay someone check please I'm gonna say
that's 19 boy that could be 74. Raiders
of the Lost Ark no no no Eduardo where
are Jesus Christ the man who would be
king I'm gonna say 74. I'll say 73 1975.
and your first guess was 64. interesting
so anyway
um you were wrong too though you were
wrong
we haven't seen in many years
and uh Sean Connery in it who you claim
to love but don't even know the year of
one of his great movies anyway my point
is this
I don't even have eyebrows you two are
complaining about your eyebrows I'm the
dick Gephart of Comedy look it up kids
it's a funny reference dick exactly why
can't you guys be better 1964.
no I'm one of those guys who have my
eyebrows are so faint yeah this morning
I had to do a thing a friend asked if I
would appear on a little uh short
segment with him for a Morning Show and
I said sure no it wasn't called eyebrow
talk that show's been canceled replaced
by monobrow corner but I went on the
show and of course they spend the first
10 minutes giving me eyebrows I don't
have and one of the things is that
sometimes they overdo it and I come out
of there and it looks like someone has
taken two pieces of electrical tape and
put them over my eyes throughout the
show and um yeah I'm suddenly Groucho
Marx what was who is the eye Joan Jones
Crawford Crawford yeah so anyway you
were saying Sona and back to the
important part that you need constant
management of your eyebrows yes how
often does this woman need to tend to
them every four weeks I think oh okay
three or four weeks would you ever want
to just let them go just to see what
would happen I did during the pandemic
pandemic yeah and what happened it you
got crazy they were all over the place
right now you probably didn't know when
it was raining like they just
they caught up they caught all the water
like you just looked at me like am I
okay come on did I go too far help me
out please no no no I just was like
you're outside and everyone's like we
gotta get inside it's pouring on you
like what are you talking about it's not
raining these giant
barriers and your friends are huddled
under yeah that's when you notice people
have you ever noticed people uh don't
stare at me so Shona in a rainstorm have
you ever noticed friends of yours
Gathering underneath you
why are you getting me to do this I
apologize I know and I appreciate that
that's why I like Matt Moore and I
um I'm glad that I captured this moment
because this was an argument that was
going to go unheard by the public I'm
also glad that I brought back the memory
of Dick Gephart yeah a famous politician
a long time ago who had no eyebrows yeah
what an incredible thing for me to
remember do you want to say anything to
me about that joke about people
Gathering under my eyebrows when it
rains I think if you I think I think
it's a good visual I think it's a funny
gag I think it's a solid joke wait oh
you want an apology
rate your joke what are you ever gonna
not rate your joke Eduardo what did you
think about huddling under the eyebrows
[Applause]
but the friends the friends comment was
I thought Gordy made that what are you
doing what are you think you are
throwing me under the bus you're new
here I'm talking about a vulnerable
situation where I'm hearing and you guys
are just making jokes about I kind of
can because I have a unibrow yeah so I'm
not joking I see yeah
yeah and that's why we got in a bit of a
fight yeah I know that's true yeah yeah
you don't even have eyebrows loser I
know Matt Smith yeah I'm a real dick
Gephart I'm telling you it's a funny
reference look it up if it didn't work
the first time it's not gonna work
podcast how do we know it's not working
I hear so many laughs out there this
hasn't gone out yet it will and I hear
so many future laughs out there people
in rental cars all across America are
howling at this one
people on their pods
what here but oh God what is happening
okay uh we gotta get started we haven't
even covered why we got in a fight in
the first place it's not not important I
don't care that's true because I said oh
do you do them yourself and then I need
you to replicate them snarky okay so so
say what happens
saying I was like Hey do you tweeze your
own middle of the eyebrows and I said no
my wife does it because I thought you
were saying like do you have some fancy
schmancy person that comes and does it
Well turns out that's a real thing I
didn't really realize so I was making a
joke about no I I take care of my
eyebrows like the common man what kind
of tool do you use uh just like uh I
don't know sometimes if I'm just
trimming my beard I'll just razor it off
with the electric razor sometimes I'll
just shave it with a razor razor if I'm
shaving I don't I don't know I don't
care I mean I'm just you know Devil May
care I'm a common man I'm a blue collar
worker you have eyebrows they're just
blonde yeah I I do have eyebrows they're
very very light and that must be hard
because most of your whole like life is
you're doing weird faces you know like
you're like you're less a get part more
of a Mondale
what wow you too
wow you two welcome to 80s
these are 80s references weren't even
funny in the 80s
next you're gonna be doing where's the
beef
yeah we lost so many of our young
listeners just now but yeah so this
lasts them a long time we've never had
them that's not true I'm really down
with the kids I'm really down with the
kids yeah cool people don't say things
like that it's true when they're off in
the clubs listening to Beck's you know
loser baby loser baby